because if you're a week around here
they're going to chill out and pray on
the week
this area is kind of crisp you got the
blood that's over there though
we're on blood side of the tracks
there's a lot of pain and a lot of
people are hurting really just don't
know no better
so what would you have to say if you
have one message to the world spending
serious money here how much are you
doing
we're the enemies you ready to get your
beanie
get y'all some 3d glasses and look at
the ceiling because it's going to take
you through a drive of where i'm from
right here i've been watching
[Music]
good morning guys here i am today with
ton from hood vlogs
we're in south central taun's
neighborhood right
uh that's where i've been living at uh
we're in 74th and hoover
74th and fig in south central los
angeles so we're gonna get into this
neighborhood the surrounding
neighborhoods
if you're like me you probably know
nothing about this part of los
angeles other than a few clips from tv
uh today we're going to cruise around
with the goal of getting a better
understanding
meeting some people and just showing you
what it's like
right now we're in the imperial course
project it's a very big housing project
i'm in watts
like juan but instead of one juan yeah
that's my music name
spent my whole life over here is watts
california what's going on with the
cameras
neighborhood watch is that working
another one of course those are run by
lapd los angeles police department
what do you guys think of those guys
over here
or no comment
you know these guys yeah i know
everybody right here do you think they
want to talk say anything i mean you
know sometimes this together we could
walk past we could swing to them
you don't want to say nothing but you
know let's walk inside yeah you can walk
by
yeah yeah
how you doing what up with it
donnie peter got it here
is this guy the mayor around here or
what the man around
the man the mayor are you okay with
being on camera is that cool
i'm just rolling on uh juan here
yeah this is my people the next
interview right here
how's his music how's this great we just
went on the world in here that's what
we're waiting on
we're waiting on the what the world
we're waiting on the world they're
coming they're coming
it's going to inspire us what's it going
to make is it going to make me drive
more aggressive am i going to be
chilling out on the beach what am i
doing
i just might as well get y'all some 3d
glasses and look at the ceiling because
it's going to take you through a drive
where i'm from right here up and watch
you get to see it coming straight at you
yeah so when you put you listen to my
music you go feel me you're going to
feel what i've been through you didn't
feel what i'm gonna feel what i've seen
that's what it is that's where my music
gonna take you you make music vlog
i do music and uh you know the reason
behind me doing the music is more so
behind
like just having like a voice and be
able to tell our story over
here like because you just get so much
overlooked when it comes to just that
particular child like that class of
music and everything
yeah it's like like damn like what about
us
so now i didn't figured out my crap
jaden figured out his dream to be able
to tell
our story not just watch story but the
imperial court story so
right you know we always get like we
wrote unheard and unnoticed
so now it's our time you get looked out
for
from the homies to the whole brother
like you just got to be strong over here
too i don't want to make it sound good
because if you're
weak around here like the week
they don't get nah they gonna chew on
you
they gonna chill out they pray on the
week they go chew on you around here
you guys have been good friends since
day one yeah yeah like real brothers oh
that's cool
three of you or they're more of you it's
more of a it's a lot of it's a lot of us
it's dope yeah that is good this [ __ ]
used to be our daddy's
[ __ ] right here we already got our
circle once we go to school
and like this this l.a like it's watch
it's cali so they got they circle when
they go to school too so this is how it
started it started in elementary
we went to glacier elementary like you
know
and we the pjs you got the 10 lines so
now let's start right here we don't get
along with the 10 lines
so we're at elementary already
we got to tell y'all we the ops over
here we're the odds
we're the boss we're the opposition
we're the enemies
for all these
the next block right here as soon as you
go right here you got content right
that's like
man so you're seeing blocks like what it
is it's like two or three blocks you got
camping up the street those are enemies
right there
so you're sandwiched between the enemies
yeah now we ain't sandwiched though but
we're between them
we got a lot of them it's a lot of
there's a lot of people that don't like
all uh well how do you how do you do
they come over here you go over there
how's it work that's how it go
yeah that [ __ ] this that's how the
streets go both ways
it goes both ways gotcha there's no hard
work right here
[ __ ] money no shoebox shoebox
money yeah whatever
shoebox money you guys are putting money
in yeah
that's the front print right there too
okay but one
you make these i see the louis this is
your business this is my business get
this on
my clothes my clothing line he designs
that all right i designed it i drew that
when this [ __ ] is sexy and all that we
taxing we taxing the [ __ ]
sweater and all that really should make
it to all them
you're betting serious
[Laughter]
that's good my boyfriend take care guys
the streets i don't want to be in the
streets forever i got kids
you know i got goals i can't pursue that
right here up in these streets you never
know what might happen
hey [ __ ] around and force my hand around
here you don't feel safe
i don't feel safe nowhere
man i don't feel safe nowhere
how often has the uh the shooting's been
happening here
you said it's been crashing yeah it's
been cracking and that's the reason why
i was saying like you know she don't
feel safe nowhere because i've been
around here my whole life like i was
just telling you
somebody could run from right here from
off that street down these corners and
start shooting
but they don't make me that nervous
because they shoot from way down there
and they shoot from way down there
is it how often probably like every
other week around here
but far as l.a like because we got
projects it's different
when they come shoot at the projects
then all the other games around
l.a that's just neighborhoods and blocks
how is it different at the projects
would you want to come up in here and
jump out right here and shoot
no it's like you know you got people all
right there you got people all right
there nobody want to get stuck up in
here
right yeah there's there's not an easy
way out yeah so that's why i said i like
to get blocked
from like somewhere right there but
literally from
right there they're standing on the
street from right there shoot or they'll
come right here
and they'll shoot like that's the only
way like they shoot they don't really
shoot up in here
this is your office yeah hey you got to
um put your order in
it takes me the size and the color you
need yeah
yeah you ready to get your beanie
yeah 25. here you go you might as well
get the whole suit man
oh
i've been drawing since i was four
god you got a lot going on here music
and a
clothing line look you'll find it weird
because look i grew up around here right
but when i started drawing i'm pretty
into amy i started drawing oh it's amy
yeah
i'm drawing okay look this is the large
right here it's black
what's this me like what's the symbolism
here what's the story
um it's just a character that i do
that i figured it'd be kind of
attractive pop into the eyes
female c and be like oh it's cute you
know
i don't know too much about marketing
but i know that much more people
are more so they can't walk past this
they're more women buying or men buying
both i got women stuff too you guys are
all
on all in with the cash app huh oh yeah
you know okay oh you ain't know
i'll go joe drop down stammies
uncle joe drop them has he dropped the
second round yet
yes he did third round third round this
is
all right this is the second for me he
gave me 1400 with his funky ass
you're gonna send joe a mask yeah i seen
joe with mass
who's on your necklace here his mom's
right here
she alive yeah nah nah okay alive and me
that's why i'm so fast to say yeah
gotcha do you see her in anything you
see her in like
trees or birds or anything or like only
time i seen her was like around
the year she passed uh-huh and she
passed 2019
i've seen her two dreams like since she
had passed
but around that time but now since then
you guys were close yeah yeah yeah that
was my mom
the mothers are the backbones would you
say yeah yeah
of course the mother is always a
backbone who got to carry us to nine
months
right gotta give credit when they do i
love our women
you married got a lady yeah
she nice she loves me you got kids yeah
yeah i got children i got four little
girls what's up baby
uh four little girls i got four i said i
said i got four little girls i got three
little girls
and um one side my partner threw me off
are they here
no no no uh i did break
break dancing back in the day i'm older
than you i'm older than you bro
but check it out check it out my
instructor said uh
come back with a street name tomorrow
and i grew up on pease road
yeah i didn't know what that meant so
i'm like i'm peter p's
as in pisses
hey baby how you doing all right it's
like its own city out here
yeah yeah well this right here is just
like his own village
like you know i say more like his own
village like
we got our own tribe you know a lot of
people look at us and they say oh gang
things hey how y'all doing hey baby
hey you know they look at us and they
think oh gangbangers gang members
right they want to do this they want to
do that but it's not necessarily that
like
it gets bad man you know sitting over
your shoulder and stuff so it feels
just stuff like this and this is hey
what's that from you know
dog oh man yeah
jesus it's people the only thing
is just that there's games behind us so
it's the same situation that other
people's might have but
it's right it's games like right at
first when games started it was as
protection from um the police and
everything
for example like chris it's um community
revolution in progress
so everything started off as that but
then as it grows started like
the violence and everything came you got
some people that feel like a family
member got killed and they don't want to
leave that alone
so it's not more about i'm wearing blue
or i'm wearing red or i'm wearing purple
yeah like at the end of the day that's
the that's the main source of it but
it's more like behind all of it this is
just a lot of pain and a lot of people
are hurting really just don't know no
better
okay you got no guidance so what would
you have to say if you have one message
you know to the world to the internet
what would you want to put out there
my message is something like you know
like your life is yours
and whatever you feel up in your heart
you got to push that like
no matter how you grew up and no matter
how your past was
no matter how your parents might want
you to you know you can't try to make
everybody happy are like you can't feel
sorry for yourself and always blame
something
just gotta pick up and live life my
message for everybody is to live life
that's what we're here for right yeah
they can try to say a whole bunch of
every nonsense that they can't prove and
say all this difficult the only thing i
could say is we here to live life enjoy
your loved ones because
you can't control the negative stuff you
can't control all that coming
but you can control how like that's what
i love about life
yeah you can never control how stuff
start but you can control how we're in
yeah so just live it up man keep a smile
on your face be positive
that's it you're great
man i appreciate it yeah thank you
[Music]
i just saw a video of this shootout it's
not far from
from where we at right now um
it's a broad daylight yeah nice houses
and uh sorry to interrupt and you can
just see someone uh
someone smashed their window twice you
sure you want to park here yeah that's
fine
all right here we are with beezy
is he busy yeah a friend of mine
his baby mother
having an altercation with him they
wasn't having words right
she came over here bashed his window in
with a bat
was he in there uh no you see she made a
couple of attempts right here the
business
right here she didn't swing hard enough
there but yeah she got in there
kind of scraped the window so she went
back to the front what's the story of
the neighborhood we're in watts right
here right
yeah this watch 117th street
and karoshi's avenue but main stories
around here is like
i say the biggest one would be my
brother been shooting the police in the
face that would be like the biggest
story around here your brother shot the
policeman in the face yeah over here
yeah was he shooting like what happened
um
they like [ __ ] with us a lot you know
like they come over here like
hit put guns in our face take our like
take our belongings
or sometimes they even come plant stuff
on this like you see it's a field right
there
and you see how we just pull it up like
say francis police
at times they'll come grab you go way
over there to the field
find whatever say they found drugs guns
or whatever and
try to throw the case on this but my
brother was fed up with that he from me
so
yeah so how is it right now the
neighborhood does it feel unsafe
does it always feel unsafe or what's the
story i mean right now
it's like we've been having a lot of
raids
they tried rage yeah this majority this
area is kind of crips you got the bloods
that's over there though
on the other side of the road there yeah
what am i seeing here this is like gang
right
you see where it's in black the cv that
stands for compton vadio that's
that's a mexican but we have a mess
inside that we're
like allies we saw the 817th street
so your allies with them some of the
mexicans this side of the neighborhood
okay okay yeah like um
no mainly in watts every like watts hood
have a mexican side to it
so it's like it's like combined pretty
much they get along
it ain't like black or mexican beef out
here like okay really messing up masking
so it's not it's not an ethnic thing
it's a it's a gang thing
yeah it's really like black on black
messing up mexicans but sometimes you'll
have
mexican hoods get into it with black
hoods gotcha but it's not like
they mainly focus on that they like
pretty much separate like i don't know
if you heard about like
how the other mafias do like the italian
mafia they maybe killed each other
that's
how it is with the games like crips and
crisp beef bloods and bloods beef
like wait wait wait so crips there's
inner rivalry in her
inner gang fighting within the gang yeah
you got ponies down there too
ponies yeah you know what yeah that's
how you know you're in watts
when you hear roosters and all that
stuff that's how you know you're gonna
watch you don't hear that every morning
so yeah everyone does what they have to
do to survive how about with covid
is like like the last year it was a big
hill
it was a help yeah that was the biggest
help ever
why i mean because people that you see
normally never have money
and develop with money you know from the
stimulus
from the stimulants from the edd from
everything
because it's unemployment so everybody
that wasn't getting money before
because because like um tom explained to
me before that people would be thinking
i'd say that the government just gave us
money no only government
the money government gives you is
probably like
two hundred dollars yeah and that's
you gotta go through so much stuff just
to get that two hundred dollars a month
but rent here i say rent for this house
probably like
twenty twenty two hundred twenty
yeah 2200 a month probably like half a
million dollar house yeah
you were born and raised how has it
changed here
changed a lot like say frances all these
houses you're seeing used to be
used they used to be black
but they got schemes and scans to get
you out of there like say for instance
you know back back in like the 80s and
stuff like that everybody was doing a
lot of drugs
yeah so they catch you and your house
have drugs in it
they use that as a reason to foreclose
your house you know and stuff like that
so
it take your house no matter how hard
you work what you did to get them
if they found drugs in your house yeah
they could take it
so a lot of these were black now more
mexican is that what you're saying
okay what are you saying about money all
right like it's so messed up out here
because they fancy i get a hundred
thousand uh-huh
but i got people that i've been
rocking with or i've been hanging with
since we was younger and stuff
and i got a group of them five but then
i also had family members
that i didn't ban with you again i'm
saying these are these five groups of
people just my friend but then i got
family members but i get a hundred
thousand
yep they gonna feel they entitled to x
amount of dollars whatever they put in
their head they're gonna feel they are
tied up to that much
so they'll be like say let's just say
each one of them like oh
he could have gave me five thousand he
could have gave me five thousand that's
25 000
that would come out of my pocket if i'd
done that you're going to understand but
what about the family members and what
about you in the future so if you're
thinking for yourself
and you put it to the side like okay i'm
gonna have to map this out because ain't
no
telling when i would get another hundred
thousand so you're like okay i'm gonna
have to do this and invest this and that
invest this and that
toward the fact you can't get them five
thousand dollars each
but you give them a thousand dollars
they're gonna feel it's not enough
so now they're gonna fail and they mine
okay he gave all of us which name so he
still got 95 000. they want more
so they go to robbing you killing you
hating on you
turning everybody against you to the
fact that they run and rob you you know
it'd be like a lot of it's a lot of
hatred
out here so it's it's dangerous to make
a lot of money
it's risky to make money here risky to
have money if they'll be here
so the people that they make their
success here they do they get out or
how does that majority of them run some
state and die some
you know some still hold it down or some
go to jail for
having to defend their money it's like
it's real risky
you don't got to be your homies it could
be your family it could be anybody
a lot of people turn against you like
it's a saying that uh
money don't change you would change the
people around you
and it's true and then the people that
mostly hated you
go to act like they was your best friend
but these are people that walk by you
you actually
ride no they can't give you no ride but
now they act like they your best friend
then you got the people that was your
best friend to feel like you're not
giving them
what they should have and now they
become to hate you
so it's a swap so it's there's like
in a way there's a disincentive to do
well because you're going to have a it's
going to be a battle right
it's going to be a better yeah if you're
going above your peers
like you'll never know who loyal to you
until you
at your worst and you at your best yeah
the only two times you'll know who loyal
to you
that's true that's universal
[Music]
a competition of ice cream trucks coming
at us
this ice cream truck passed the other
guy
now he's a little bit upset
dude thank you
[Music]
what is this you got something in a
frida's pack oh yeah chili cheese fritos
they put chili and cheese on the frito
cost like a dollar fifty
they just cut the bag open fill it up we
just raised on this
do you love horses i do
i don't like that um
my dream was to have one and always
write it what grade are you in
i'm in fourth grade okay are you guys in
school now or no
uh no they said in a few months after
all the teachers get like their tests
are you are you missing school no no
i do not like school you like horses
yes
online
see bloods in the crits they only become
together when
either whites or mexicans are trying to
jump up on us
then that's when bloods and christians
jump up on you what do you mean like
like they're trying to gang in
like no i'm coming in jail for them like
on the streets it's like pretty much wow
it's like a wild card
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
on the street okay once you get to jail
it's politics you can't do whatever you
want to now everything you do be
answered to
so you can go as much to
you don't like this person you go stab
this person but now once you make it
over there
the people that with your friends on the
streets gonna end up having to do
something to you for what you did to
that person
even though they was your enemy on the
street because once you're in there
that's not your enemy that's your homie
now once you get back to the streets you
can do whatever you want to but
you end up in you [ __ ] around and end up
back in there
and now you have to be together the
enemy of your enemies your friends
and that's how it works here yeah and
it's like it's bigger than you so it
don't matter if you think it
it's about what everybody thinks it's
about about what all the content
and all of watson then the money tree
because i got a
my brother that shot the police in the
face he had five kids he left behind
let me know my bad seven kids i got the
five kids my bad wow
he got uh seven kids he left behind and
i do for them as i do for mine where are
they where are the kids
um they with their mom spread it out
through their moms and stuff but i make
sure i do for them as i do for mine so
that's where this come in by me saying
like the family tree i put money
into it so that's what the money
treating the family
busy good luck with everything man you
too just waiting for ton
i want to mention that uh well this is
one story today right we're going in
talking to a few people khan's friends
and just getting their their voices out
on camera
and by no means am i any expert
or really know what's going on in these
neighborhoods i have no clue
to be honest but i want to bring you
guys in on the street level
just to give a taste of what it's like
you know
with the people what the people have to
say and whatnot
uh this place to understand
i gotta say would take quite a bit of
time
definitely not in a day or week a month
even a year like there's a lot going on
there are a lot of moving parts here
so i want to make that very clear
don what's this place it's a famous
restaurant
hawkins is right across from the
nickerson garden housing
it's just project very famous full spot
over here nah watts
ton seems to be like a well-known man
and he's all over the internet as you'll
see in his videos
is it all right if you're on yeah yeah
okay [ __ ] yeah
okay uh showing us the best burger
choice oh yeah
this hawkish man you know nixon guards
across the street from the projects man
offense man we're in watts california
watch california we're going to watch
california man you know what i'm saying
parking south we're on uh we're on blood
side
of the tracks right now
yeah man we don't we don't know you know
we on that side man but you make music
right that's your big thing yeah yeah
yeah
man gg man you know how i get it in man
make that music gorilla for bread you
know what i'm saying
live man why city california you know
what's going on
you know what i'm a saying business
right here
yeah this is a family business owned by
a family you know what i'm saying that
they own
boss hey how's it what's the pandemic
done in your neighborhood does it slow
things down enough well
no no i can't really you know
hard to say it's hard to say you know
the pandemic ain't really slowing that
down
you know you mean it's like people got
richer than the pandemic you know what
i'm saying
right it's more like people got richer
than that
you've been doing you've been making
your music the whole time i just dropped
a new song man
you know called [ __ ] [ __ ] man look it
up man
gg [ __ ] look that [ __ ] up
what's that about man it's about [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm gonna keep grinding man you know
gorilla for bread comes from the bottom
you know what i'm saying
we're gonna go to the top you know what
i mean that's how we're trying to get it
you know what i'm saying
you're working hard you work hard
anymore yeah yeah man
like probably the most and i work real
hard with the music
what inspires you to make music uh my
city and my people
like really you know i got a lot of
support out here in the city you know
i'm saying in and out the community and
[ __ ]
so it's like that's what keeps me going
you guys got a strong community
out here yeah yeah yeah he's stronger
than me
he's good yeah yeah we're gonna we're
gonna leave your link below too yeah man
let's
drop the [ __ ] link we're going
viral man
anything anything is going to be good
all right
i'm in nice meeting you thank you take
care
okay fish taco and chicken taco please
it took what an hour like 45 minutes
probably
but everyone here says this is the this
place is the bomb
is it cool if i eat on your hood all
right
oh yeah good crispy chicken soft taco
shell
simple lettuce tomatoes cheese all right
guys thanks for coming along
you gotta check out tons hood vlogs i'll
leave the link below
it's awesome he goes into pretty much
all the big american cities and gets in
deep
way deeper than we got in today so check
out his content and then i'll have the
other guys contents
music links below in the description
thanks ton all right guys check out his
channel thanks for coming along
until the next one
you ready